es ist jetzt einfach gehen wir machen
das video an was wird man direkt an
wir meinen eröffnet
[Musik]
okay leute also wir in dem punkt glaube
diese erklärung freu dich du bist uns
schuldig als diese etwa und verlässt die
frage immer wieder aufgekommen wieso
macht ihr keine videos liga konkurrenz
einfach mal gemacht dass wir für die
deutsche hp tochter drauf machen kommen
wir hier noch nie wieder sehen
wir beantworten einfach meisten fragen
die frage warum wir keine videos mehr
zusammen machen wie wir das beantworten
wir haben einfach auseinandergelebt mal
wirklich viele leute fragen wie höhere
karies miteinander macht man auch beim
letzten video ist ja dass alle leute
geschrieben
man merkt richtig jahr hat luca
vollstreckung die panne richtig
geschrieben waren sagen der ganzen
geschichte luca wie lange in amerika
eine besondere zeit man sagen dass ich
versucht den dreißigsten haben und nicht
regelmäßig mehr gesehen weil ich den tag
normalerweise einfach hier drei tage in
berlin weist wieder hier dann war ich
jeden tag in amerika dann war ich wieder
jedes verlagen in berlin als die
hackordnung und ich bin oder nicht der
star bestritt richtig dann war ich in
die datei auch mal vier fünf tagen zwei
meiner familie und praktikum genau ich
hatte euch in unserer zeit ein praktikum
berichtet acht stunden am tag ein
facharbeiter was für youtube für eine
station wird am rande der schmerzgrenze
internationalisierung traktor hatte eine
formatierung wird am rande der
schmerzgrenze warum engagiert mit ihr
bekommen einfach alles in allem es war
einfach wirklich nicht möglich also viel
video zusammen machen wir waren auf
jeden fall ein paar mal trainieren das
auto mal gesehen
so glaubt nicht wie uns ab und in
manchen akku mit bedauern aber nicht
denn mit kurze anfrage
ich wollte gar keinen streit
wir machen das jetzt irgendwann den weg
bin fertig mit dem praktikum machen dann
sind wir auch die vermarkter für drei
tage in berlin für drei tage in berlin
und beim konsum ab und hat dort auch
bereit schauen also ja nie wissen willst
wie mögen jetzt würde ich einen schlag
so ein bisschen die nadel unter video zu
strecken
[Applaus]
[Musik]
voller ernst wird